this is Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky
welcome to a battle of Titans at the
2022 fide World Blitz Championship
yukara Nakamura with the white pieces
faces Sasha grishock one of the best
Blitz players in the world one of the
top Grandmasters in the world and I
don't know about that opening Choice
karishuk starts the game off with a
French that is a dangerous opening to
play in a Blitz game but Hikaru he
doesn't respond with Knight C3 he
responds with the tarash variation which
is of course one of the most reputable
ways to beat the French the Knight
situates itself on D2 rather than C3
grishek immediately strikes at the
center Hikaru captures the pawn on C5
that is a sideline that's not a very
well-known variation and that triggered
a relatively short think by Grisha as he
delays the recapture on C5 first he
focuses on forcing white to give up the
rest of his Pawn Center we have a trade
on D5 Hikaru develops on F3 and Nakamura
not really playing the opening all that
ambitiously I think grishek has already
solved all of his problems as he
recaptures the pawn on C5 both sides
calmly continuing their development
white sending his Bishop out to D3
potentially eyeing that H7 Pawn after
black Castle's King side and white is
also very likely to Castle kingside here
as well so both kings are going to be
relatively safe for the foreseeable
future I think the battle is largely
going to revolve around who can situate
their minor pieces better and more
harmoniously as Grisha dials his Queen
back to C7 that is a very typical Square
for the queen in these types of
variations it's safe from all attacks by
whites minor pieces and I really like
the way that Sasha is handling the
opening as well as his clock he's up 22
seconds not something that you say every
day about Alexander grishock Hikaru
pushes his Pawn up to C3 I thought he
might have wanted to play B3 in
fianchetto his dark scored Bishop
instead he moves upon up to C3 and
vacates uh the C2 Square for his Queen
so the Queen's gonna move up to C2 uh
White's gonna build a battery against
that H7 Pawn or Grisha could play H6
whenever he wants to so the position
remaining pretty common I jinxed him you
he was up on time a move ago he is now
down on time and I think that's where
grishek feels the most comfortable is he
gonna play Rook to d8 here and harass
the D3 Bishop well that might be
counterproductive because white can play
Queen C2 and that actually protects the
bishop on D3 instead grishek focuses on
completing the development of his minor
pieces he plays B6 saying if you don't
want to feed Kettle then I will B6
preparing the fianketo of his light
scored bishop and the Knight on B8 in
these types of French structures it
usually comes out to D7 in order to be
able to jump later on to C5 and Hikaru
continues to pressure the queen side
that's why he played A4 that early in
order to blast through the queen side
and induce some weaknesses but it has
come at the cost of a pawn grishok says
thank you very much I'll take it Hikaru
says give me that pawn back rishik says
no he develops his Knight to C6 and with
his last move Knight D2 to B3 Hikaru has
opened up a pathway for his dark squared
Bishop to develop itself nicely to G5
and both sides have finally completed
their minor piece development we are now
officially in a very interesting
positional middle game again it's not
about King safety here both kings are
completely safe it's about who can claim
superiority on the queen side and is
Hikaru going to justify that positional
Pawn sacrifice on A5 and he's reaping
the benefits of that sacrifice right now
as he positions his Knight on C5 trying
to force black slide Squad Bishop back
to its initial square and if Grisha
decides to give that Bishop up then
we're going to get an opposite colored
Bishop structure where white can
position his Bishop on e4 that's a
pretty dominant square and White's going
to control light squares on both sides
of the board so a pretty unpleasant
dilemma here for Alexander grishak he
might have underestimated the power of
this knight jump 2 C5 the big question
is he going to keep his light Square
Bishop no he's not he's going to play
Rook f8 to d8 and now the decision is in
Hikaru Sans he says all taken Knight
takes B7 and now I think he's going to
unpin his Queen is he gonna put it on E2
or is he gonna put it on C to another
big position decision for Nakamura he
decides on Queen C2 and I think the
reason is because this move comes with
Tempo he attacks the pawn on H7 Grisha
has to honor that and he does but here
comes the bishop on to E4 it goes and
now you've got a mega pin not only is
the Knight pin to the queen now it's
pinned to the rook and Hikaru can
continue playing with Tempo uh by
jumping his Queen up to A4
so essentially he can win the pawn back
whenever he wants to and he decides to
do it right now he gives his Bishop up
but he wins The Pawn on A5 he leaves
Chris shook with a weak Pawn on A7 which
Hikaru continues to harass by doubling
his Rooks on the a file that Bishop on
F6 is also not very happy because it's
biting on granite it's staring at the
pawn on C3 as we see Anish giri there
putting on a suit check and there's
another game that catches his attention
but this game is about to heat up as
grishek Falls to a minute on the clock
he's slightly worse on the board black
is still very solid everything's
defended but Hikaru loves these types of
technical grindy positions where he can
play a million moves and keep his small
Advantage you can see him there a very
patient H3 building up his time
Advantage building up the advantage on
the board and grishek trying to find the
best way to coordinate his pieces and
keep all of his bases covered he can try
to attack the B2 Pawn but Hikaru can
defend it whenever he wants to by moving
The Rook up to A2 instead grishok he
says I'm not happy on F6 I'm gonna move
my Bishop over to B6 a very ingenious
maneuver and the bishop upon B6 is
actually going to be doing something
it's going to be pressuring the pawn on
F2 and it's going to be protecting the
D4 Square which otherwise could be used
as an outpost for White's Knight Hikaru
could play Knight T4 instead he moves
The Rook up to A6 very deliberate move
there and he pushes the pawn up to C4
Hikaru continuing to make claims on the
queen side and continuing to expand that
pawn it's currently restrained by
Black's pieces but it's still a
protected passer the pawn on C4 could
get really menacing if the Queens are
off the board and Grisha determined that
that won't happen moves his Queen up to
C5 building a battery of his own against
the F2 pawn and trying to keep White's
Queen at Bay and he moves The Rook back
to B8 a sign of anxiety there Grisham
made that move pretty nervously he
continues to take down on the clock but
Hikaru he's got to find a way to keep
tightening the screws he's done a good
job of it so far but so is grishook who
moves his Rook back to B8 and I think
grishok is preparing to move the C8 Rook
over to d8 and try to get as many Rooks
off the board as possible Hikaru says be
my guest he car is probably okay with
Rook trade as well because with every
heavy piece that disappears from the
board the value of the Pawn on C4
increases so it's not entirely clear
that trades of the Rooks the trade trade
of the Queens favors black and with 30
seconds on the clock Chris it just
doesn't have time to burn on this
decision he moves his Pawn up to A5
trying to find the optimal defensive
Arrangement on the queen side Bishop
back to A7 great shot by grishek there
he's moved his Queen to an ideal Square
both defensively and in terms of
counter-attacking the F2 Pawn Hikaru
trying to find a way to stir the pot he
takes on d8 he decides to trade a pair
of Rooks but the downside is that he has
given up control of the D file and there
are tactics in the air like Rook d8 to
D3 it's not really possible right now
because the Rook on E1 is defended but
it could be possible in the future but
krisha he's down to 15 seconds Bishop up
to B6
supporting the pawn on A5 inviting
Hikaru to move his own Rook up to E5 and
knock that Queen away first Hikaru
expands on the king side H4 setting the
preconditions for a potential attacker
when that is a risky move that is a
risky move by grishook as Magnus Carlson
comes to observe the game there might be
a sacrifice on G6 there might be a sack
on F7 I don't know about that last move
greshik uses his king that's like a
goalkeeper coming out to kick the corner
kick he uses his King to defend the
pawns but guard drops the Knight back to
F3 and the problem is that that Knight
is going to head to G5 and that's going
to create a host a Litany of threats on
the king side when the eight seconds on
the clock I don't know if Grisha is
going to be able to keep all of his
bases covered there goes the Knight onto
G5 it goes five seconds for grishook he
moves his Queen up to F6 and it's met
with a brilliant move Rook to E3
threatening workout three grocery second
he's gotta move and he makes the move
just in time but he's blundered Rook
takes E6 he's blundered Rook takes E6
and he pays the price for giving away
the G5 scripted card isn't playing
instead he goes Rook F3 and one second
o'clock Rook takes F7 that's an
alternate win if Rook F7 the Knight
captures on E6 and wins black screen
what a positional effort by Hikaru
Nakamura as he wins an impressive game
and if you enjoyed this video make sure
to click the link in the playlist for
more of these Blitz videos thank you so
much for watching
[Music]